now
Here's how it works. We're Gonna
Take turns drawing one of these cars each card has five totally random questions on it one two three fake back. Thank you yet, then
No, I love ya, that's it. I love it. Now. Does it does it does it touch this sequence?
That's it very good
One person asks the questions the other person has to answer each question as soon as it's asked and I mean immediately
It doesn't matter if the answer is right or wrong just has to be the very first thing that pops into your head
Wilson's you're the Guest I'll read your questions first. Are you ready? Yeah here we go
Why is the sun so hot uh yellow what are?
What are what are birds made out of plastic? How old is Jon hamm? Uh?
What was Elvis's first word peacock?
Who stole the eggs uh Larry and his family brother?
Learn his brother larry and his brother stole the eggs
Yellow okay yeah. Yeah, okay? No yeah, you can all ask questions own. You're ready. I'm dizzier. That was great, okay
What can I buy for a dollar?
Sandwich well where are the children hiding in the basement?
What are sports things?
How heavy is a duck 12 pounds? Tell me a secret
Shampoo
is A
Gassy secret
Dad go to juice easy juicing here. We go. All right Mm-hmm
lights
Which rabbit is the best uh?
Joe how how big is the Big man uh?
He's he's bigger
He's he's bigger than you. Think he is but he's smaller than a jockey
Why work why were you late for my wedding because my dad said?
knock it off
name the best place oh
Alaska
What are the names of the two firemen there's a?
Captain Ron
Captain Ron yes, yes and cecil
All right it fits, right
It's the final round so here's how to do it is good that
I'm this time around we'll both pick up a card with the same set of questions
I'll ask you answered then you ask the question and we'll just back and forth back and Forth Since King Kong yeah ready, okay?
Who drank all the coffee my mom did she was thirsty where did the money go? I'm just the mattress?
What does the name of your first kiss um?
What would have been a better name for the Beatles this discreet? Oh?
What what is a jazz boy? Uh? He's the guy who?
carries the saxophone
How many people are there in Canada three?
What are you? I'm me. What's a cool greeting. Hola
Why are you so great because it's in the genes. Uh sing me a song
Orlando
That was the fast barrel in the house indeed June 30th